es ging nicht mehr viel auf den straßen
von barcelona am donnerstagmorgen
nachdem ein heftiges gewitter durch die
spanische stadt gezogen war stand das
wasser auf den straßen und brachte den
verkehr fast vollständig zum erliegen
auf amateur aufnahmen waren schwimmen
der müllcontainer zu sehen und fahrzeuge
die sich mühsam durch die wassermassen
kämpfen darum herum wütete das unwetter
wegen der überschwemmungen mussten viele
u bahn stationen geschlossen bleiben
der spanische wetterdienst forderte die
bevölkerung auf vorsichtig zu sein
auch in anderen orten im norden von
spanien und teilweise auch im süden von
frankreich gab es heftige gewitter dort
soll es auch gehagelt haben